Well,
there's lots of things you do from a
practical point of view,
a secretary learns how to say,
um,
questions like,
well,
maybe you should call the social work
department first before we booked this
appointment.
Or,
um hmm,
the schedule looks really full.
All of those things are honestly
practical things.
Doctors do
second,
many of the larger hospitals like my
own,
um,
have a free care pool and we'll have
people apply to it so that they can get
their care.
But there are delays built into that.
And,
and you see that happen.
Um,
the next thing though is that when
you're committed to the idea that,
look,
I want to help anybody I can coming in
the door.
Um,
you still have the questions of how to
arrange for their care and manage it.
I can't tell you how dramatically my
practice changed.
When the Massachusetts health reform
went through.
We went from being a state with about 12
percent uninsured and that was about the
percentage of my patients who could not
pay for my treatments.
And,
and,
you know,
I would forgo the surgery costs and the
hospital would eat the,
the,
um,
the medical bills,
but you'd still have to figure out how
are they going to pay for outpatient
chemotherapy,
certain kinds of radiation treatments,
things like that.
And it was a nightmare over and over
again.
And um,
when the reform bill came through,
well,
we put this way.
It's been two years and I've not had a
patient in those circumstances for my
state.
Um,
uh,
since then.
And uh,
and it's,
you almost don't notice that used to
grapple with these issues all the time.
I face ethical dilemmas all the time.
Um,
their routine.
the 19 year old patient who,
uh,
sticks in my mind because right before
the Massachusetts health reform came
through,
I'd seen her and she had a metastatic
thyroid cancer.
Her cancer had really spread widely.
We did the surgery and then it turned
out that she needed chemotherapy and
radiation,
but her insurance coverage ran out.
She only had a,
had a $75,000 cap on her policy and she
didn't want me to tell her parents about
her condition,
um,
because she knew they would try to find
a way to pay for all of this,
that,
that is a kind of ethical dilemma.
Um,
it would seem to me a no brainer.
I called her parents
and sure enough know they,
they got a second mortgage on their
house.
They found a way to make damn well sure
their daughter got the treatment she
needed.
Um,
but you have everything ranging from
someone who um,
uh,
doesn't want to leave the hospital.
They,
they are in the hospital and um,
there were better.
But um,
you know,
they just,
they,
uh,
things are kind of a mess at home and
they'd love a couple of extra days in
the hospital even though it's $2,000 a
day.
How,
how,
how do you grapple effect?
Do you kick them out?
How do you kick them out?
Or do you just say,
well,
you know,
this is my patient.
What,
what,
what they,
they're the customer with what they say
goes.
And,
um,
uh,
you can't,
you,
you find moral questions are,
I'm a daily part of what you do as a
physician and a part of what makes it so
interesting.